[Music]
hello my name is sebastián garcía and I am
cost merengue in the google
cloud team today I am going to talk about data
flow which is a
batch processing and streaming system of google cloud
traditionally when we want to
process data we have two options to
do it  in streaming to have
immediate results but this is at the
cost of having less precise results
or doing it in batches to have
more precise results but then
this takes longer to obtain before
this problem the lambda architecture arises
in which we create a
data flow that can  deal with streaming data
and give results
immediately and on the other hand we have
a data flow in which we process
the data in batches and it is in charge of
processing the data once it is
complete to have these
very precise results
to solve this problem  there are
different solutions such as
apache storm to process
streaming data or hadoo  p to process data
in batches but the problem is that
we normally wait a long time to
have these results and also as is
the case in this image we have two
different code bases in which we
process the same data and this
always generates more complication than it
really is.  we want is to have a
unified data model that avoids maintaining two
different data streams for this
we can use the apache beam sdk
which defines a data stream and
we have a single ip to be able to do
things like define fixed
mobile windows sessions and be able to perform
calculations based on these beam windows as
well, but in ways of issuing
results quickly before the
data is complete and it takes
care that the data that arrives
later arrives late and
is recalculated in order to
then have complete and accurate results for
these data flows.  data is
also portable with bing you can choose
where to run your code you can
run it in sparc you can run it in
link in apex and in google cloud a flow
now it is google cloud tie it data
flow as we said it is a
batch processing and streaming data flow service but everything is in
the same service which avoids  having
these two code bases and having two
different technologies is fully
managed what does this mean you
don't have to worry about starting
instances configuring clusters for
absolutely nothing you just have
to submit your task and data flow takes
care of the rest the model
data flow programming was the basis
for what is now the
apache beam open source project and this is
maintained by the community and data flow
is simply a distribution of this
project lastly it is important to
mention that data flow scales to
millions of operations  per
second automatically and also the service
can scale both up
and down this means that  e when
you have a very large data flow
you can increase the number of
instances that are processing but
when this data flow decreases in the
same way scale down in this
way you only pay for what you use
and well what data sources can we
use with data  flow and where we can
write this processed data
here we have some examples as
data sources we can use things like
bic google vic query cloud storage pop
soft big time bold data store and as
destinations we can basically use the
same vicoer and storage of shop but
these are clear  the origins and destinations
of google cloud but data flow and apache
beam that also allow you to connect with
other types of services
as we mentioned then data flow is
a service to execute flows of the
apache bean platform and that includes
this platform well there are four
basic concepts the first  they are the
pipelines or flows of procedures
that encapsulate the entire task of
p  end-to-end
processing this includes reading the data transforming it maybe grouping it
formatting and then writing it
then we have a pick collection a
pick collection represents a set
of data on which the data flow
for operations will either process or
calculate this set of  data is very
particular because because it can be
limited as in the case of a
fixed source let's say a file but it
can also be potentially unlimited
when we are reading from a
data source that is continually updated
such as a message queue or
another mechanism
is also  It is important to emphasize that these
sets are immutable, this
means that once created, elements cannot be
added, deleted or modified,
what happens is that we operate on
each of the elements of this collection and
these produce another different collection
or a different tropic collection with
the  modified data
we also have what is  they call pi
transformers which are the
data changes this represents a
data processing operation or step in the
processing flow each of these
and transform takes an api collection as
input and can perform some calculation and
power and then has a null output
can  be or with one more for collections
finally we have the
input and output transformations that as we saw
before allow us to read data from
different sources and at the same time write them
in different systems
let's see now it is complete up to the
top we have our data flow
which is what  we are going to program then
we have the libraries that we are going to
use to apache bin being an
open source project we have a multitude
of libraries to use that can
help us do our transformation
this includes for example the sources and
destinations that we have for our
project then we have  to choose
which of each to use the most
popular option is ha  ok but we can also
use python and even scale although we
must also emphasize that scale
is not something properly maintained by google
cloud but it is becoming more and more popular
after we implement our
data flow with different functions and once
we have our data flow
we have to  choose where to run it as
we mentioned for this I can use
a cloud data flow spark of link and
finally we have to choose the execution environment
this can be in the cloud with cloud data
flow on a server of your own or even on
your laptop to test
let's see now  a more concrete example of
how it works here we have a
very simple data flow in which in the
first part we are reading from a
text file that we specify from
the command line
then we apply the count words function
to count the words in the file
later  we format this
data with the text formats function and
finally we write the results  in a
new text file
let's now see a slightly
simpler example in this example we are reading
from pop shop which is our
message queue system that we are
subscribing to a topic there and we are
reading each of the messages that
arrive in this case  we have a
potentially infinite data collection
then we are applying a
one second window this window is
where we will do our calculations or
processing with the elements that
are within that
time window then we are
mapping our elements to create pairs
of key value then we are
counting them by the key that we have
then we format with the
transform lights function and finally we
rewrite the data by sun
this is a slightly more
complicated example but we can still see how
we can use different elements that
apache beam provides us to do
relatively complex things with little code
with this you  we finished this first
introduction to google cloud data flow
start using google data flow
from today on cloud dot google.com
diagonal data flow
thank you